good morning and welcome to a sky news
vaccine special now this morning we're
joined live
by the deputy chief medical officer for
england professor jonathan
van tam for a vaccination q a
he's going to be taking your questions
live in just a moment and we have been
inundated with subjects that you want to
ask him about
in the next half now we'll be discussing
the vaccine roll out
the scientific route out of lockdown and
also hesitancy from some
to actually get the jab lots to get
through so let's crack on shall we let's
get started welcome to the program
uh professor thank you so much for
joining us we've had absolutely
loads of questions in
good morning i gather you have uh yes so
i'm really keen to just get through as
many as we can and to get some of your
expertise as the rollout
of course gets underway we know how
important it is to the look down at
easing
as well and some of the questions we've
had about supply
and a bit a worry basically about the
drop in numbers
this is the first question since we hit
the first
15 million jabs target there's been a
drop off in the daily vaccination
numbers why
well that's really very simple to
explain
there are always going to be supply
fluctuations
these are new vaccines by and large the
manufacturers have not made them or
anything
like them before and
the process of making a vaccine is one
where
basically you kind of set set the
equipment up
and leave it all to kind of do its thing
a bit like beer making really
and um what you get at the end is not
something
that you can say is identical every time
in terms of the yield the amount of
doses that you can then make from that
batch
as it were so you do get kind of batch
size variations
and that's kind of natural and it's
going to take a few months before
the manufacturers really get into this
very confident
very steady manufacturing routine
and on top of that there are global
supply constraints
you know in the uk we are in an amazing
place compared to
so many parts of the world and
um you know everybody is looking for
vaccines
we've been very clever we've been
very much on the front foot in getting
access to vaccines
as you know we have secured supplies
of many more many more types and they
will come on stream gradually
at different time points and at
different rates throughout
2021 but am i confident
in the long term that we are absolutely
going to be able to
meet our ambitions um through vaccine
supply
yes i actually i am and um do i think
that uh
this slow down that uh you know
is evidenced by the numbers in the last
few days is going to suddenly pick up a
game
uh yes i do um it's good to hear your
confidence
at the same time i guess some people
listening to your answer might be a bit
worried about the
the as you say the global supply
constraints and also the fact that as
you say like the beer making process
there are certain uncertainties to
manufacturing vaccines
can you guarantee that everyone who's
had their first vaccine will certainly
be able to get that second
within the 12-week limit set
that is absolutely the plan and
um you know i'm not going to make
guarantees around
an individual who's uh you know called
and can't make that appointment or
something happens like that
but yes absolutely i can um
and you know it's factored in by the nhs
um colleagues uh in terms of
um you know how much vaccine they uh
they distribute it's factored in that
very soon
we're going to have people who are
coming up to their
um 12-week mark and are going to need
their second doses
and there's going to be quite a lot of
people from now on um who are going to
need to start needing their second doses
but that's all planned in
um looking at another question we've had
in from june wilson this is in romford
she said i've had my first jab and i'm
being told it could be 12 weeks
before my second manufacturers say it
should be no more than six what's your
advice i think it's worth talking
specifically
about pfizer here because obviously we
know there's slightly different
situations about
astrazeneca and pfizer where they have
different guidance what would you say to
june
yeah well we've always said that um our
jcvi has looked at the data on pfizer
and calculated that at the time where
they
cut off their data uh with the with the
second dose being given
essentially at 21 days the vaccine
effectiveness at that point
is in the very high 80 and
we've always said that you know there's
no vaccine in the world that gives you
that kind of effectiveness and then just
drops off a cliff
at day 22 or day 23 it'll be high for
quite some time and we're now seeing
that
with the um data from health protection
scotland that were published on monday
and they've looked um for both
pfizer and for astrazeneca on the effect
of vaccines so far
which means that first dose
in reducing covid related
hospitalization
and that's a really big thing if you can
keep out of hospital
and the um percentage effectiveness in
avoiding hospital for pfizer
is 85 and for
astrazeneca is 94
so a really tremendous
um effect and that was measured at up to
35 days
so that's well beyond the 21 days when
pfizer in particular say a second dose
should be given
and it's beginning to give us real world
confidence now
not just science confidence in based on
what we
know from first principles but actually
data confidence
that the priority first day strategy
is going to work and that it is the
right thing to do
now on top of that i'm sorry to go on
sophie but azad oxford
also submitted some scientific papers
which are in the public domain on their
vaccine
showing that actually a an interval
longer than six weeks is um
much more beneficial in terms of getting
the second dose
and in terms of having a very high
long-term
effectiveness so for the az vaccine in
particular
there is really no rush um to get this
i'm quite confident that we're going to
see an effect
um that lasts those 12 weeks and that
for azad it's absolutely clear you're
going to get better long-term protection
if you don't rush back and have your
second dose some really
um encouraging data there and you know
the who as well the world health
organization updating their advice uh
too
i'm keen to move on to vaccine hesitancy
because we have had quite a lot of
questions from viewers who
you know i wouldn't say they're
anti-vaxxers but they're people who have
concerns hesitancy around taking
the vaccine one question for example
anonymous how do you know the vaccine
will not affect my chances of
infertility
samantha from lincolnshire asks how can
vaccines be approved as safe
when we cannot know about the potential
long-term side effects
five or ten years down the line what
would you say
okay so how do i know the vaccine will
not affect my chances of
fertility first of all it is just
not biologically logical that they would
secondly no vaccine has ever
done this but i can say that um
for people who are at risk and who are
being called for vaccines
um getting covered does affect your
long-term chances of life
and and that's a pretty important
counter balance but um
there are just no data and it's not
biologically logical
that fertility is going to be affected
and
no vaccine has ever done that on the
second point about um i think it was
about
long-term side effects did you say
sophie yeah that's right and what how do
you how do you know that there
is about long-term side effects five or
ten ten years down the line
yeah well almost all side effects occur
um in days and if not in days
then in weeks and
if we took a view that we were going to
wait for
side effects that are incredibly rare
um if they occurred at all five or ten
years later
then you know every time there was a new
vaccine or a new medicine
we'd be waiting 10 years to
reap the benefits of it and there are
patients who are going to die
next month if they don't have the
vaccine this month
that's the reality of this and the pace
at which this has happened
not only in the uk but around the world
means that
you know we've done 17
million first doses already more than 17
million
in the uk um the mhra looks for safety
signals we're getting
nothing that is of concern now
if you say that we've done 17 and the
israelis have done this much and you
know you're getting into kind of
many tens of millions yeah can you
imagine how many people
we will have done globally five to ten
years from now
and then if you get a side effect
can you imagine how rare that is going
to be you know one in
however many billion or something uh set
against the risks of covid
um so that's why um i think
the issue is that we've done so many
people already
and we're just not having any safety
signals
how concerned are you about vaccine
hesitancy
disproportionately in certain
communities i know there's been a lot
about
people in black and minority ethnic
communities being less likely to
take the job also people in more
working-class communities as well
how concerning is it what does your data
show
yeah i am concerned about this
and i expect um the uh the nhs to
um publish data on on uptake in due
course
but i am concerned about it i know there
is hesitancy
in some of the black and minority ethnic
communities
and i know you know it's been a an issue
for decades that it is always
more difficult to
get high uptake of vaccines and other
preventive
health care services in areas of
unfortunately low
um low prosperity
um you know high deprivation in the uk
so
this is not a new problem
but it is one that greatly concerns me
because
um we need very high uptake as
as sir patrick valance explained on tv
the other day
um you know we need very high uptake of
these vaccines
to give us the best chance of moving
from where we are now which let's face
it is quite a bit better
than where we were a month ago to where
we really want to be
by the time the road map is complete in
the in the early summer
what kind of uptake do you need because
there's different levels of uptake
needed for different diseases aren't
there like measles for example you need
very high level of vaccination what do
you think it is for covid
right so it's never ever been an
ambition
uh to achieve herd immunity and um
you only start to talk about you know
the kind of level of vaccine
uh uptake you need to achieve herd
immunity when that's
even possible what we're talking about
here
is just de-linking
the association between getting coveted
and ending up in hospital for as many
people
as possible and the way to do that is
obviously to stop them
getting covered in the first place which
is the vaccine
and then even though we know vaccines
are never 100
effective we already
see the data on these reduced
hospitalizations
that vaccines make it much less likely
that you'll end up in hospital even if
you do have
covid at the end of the vaccine
so from you know from that perspective
um or despite the vaccine
so from that perspective um there is no
magic number here
it's just as high as we can get it and
the really good news
is that um we didn't expect vaccine
to be as uptake to be as high as it has
been
you know it's been consistent as we've
gone down the priority groups it's been
consistently 90 plus percent 90 plus
percent
every time and uh so uh you know
it's clear the vast majority of the uh
the the uh
british public who are at risk who have
been called for their vaccines get it
that it's really important and i was
vaccinating yesterday and uh there was a
lady came in and said i really don't
like needles
uh doctor and i really don't like
vaccines
um but i know i've got to have this one
i just know i've got to
and i said well yeah you're absolutely
right you know you framed it
good news that you've got your first
dose congratulations on that um
question from sandia quite an important
question actually
is it safe to visit my parents once
we've all had
our first jabs they're in their 70s with
pre-existing conditions i think a lot of
viewers will be wondering the same thing
at what point after
to get your first dose is it safe to see
your family
right okay once you've had a first dose
of vaccine
it's going to take between two and three
weeks
before antibody levels build up to the
point where i would judge
you have some meaningful protection on
board
but a first dose is a first dose and you
need a second dose
and it will take longer for elderly
people to mount the antibody response we
absolutely know that
and we know that from the covert 19 data
we have now already so that's the first
thing to say don't assume that vaccines
give you this kind of
you know colgate ring around you the
moment you've had one and then you're
kind of instantly protected
i'm afraid it doesn't work like that and
you also need your second dose
um does it become safer to mix
after we've had vaccines um yes
it does become safer as opposed to the
question
which was safe because we don't yet
fully know or have
confidence that vaccines are going to
stop us
um passing the virus on one to another
and um even if it's safer
i'm afraid you can't do it um
we've laid out or the government has
laid out a
pretty careful and pretty painstakingly
cautious but i think appropriate
road map to get us from where we are now
through in stages measured careful
stages to where we want to be
in the summer and uh you know again i'm
saying it to
um uh you know the patients that i
vaccinate
and um some of them will be no doubt
watching you and going oh yeah he said
that to me yesterday
all of the rules apply to all of us
whether we're vaccinated or not
according to the road map until we can
get out of this
um completely as a nation
okay yes some really important advice uh
there on the
timeline after you have your dose um i
was interested to hear you say actually
about the fact that you're not going for
herd immunity and but you're trying to
reduce the
hospitalizations and deaths and i think
this links into the next question
actually from jane barrett
she asks does vaccination prevent the
occurrence of long
covid something lots of people are
worried about you might not of course
end up in hospital
um with serious complications but you
might have health
impacts that could last for some time
after
yeah so the answer to that one is is
quite yes but no but
in that the sense that do we have can i
look your viewer in the eye and say do i
at this point in time
have categorical data on vaccinated
versus unvaccinated
and the incidence of long covert the
likelihood of getting
long covert no i don't at this point in
time
however can i say that you can't get
long covered
if you don't get infected yes i
absolutely can
and do we have clear evidence from the
clinical trials
and now from our own real world
observational data here
in the uk that vaccines even after the
first dose
begin to significantly prevent infection
yes i can okay um a big question that's
been in the news
a lot lately about vaccine passports uh
this was sent in to us from one of our
viewers
when we can continue to traveling in
europe would vaccine passports be a part
of routine testing
at the border now i know partly this is
a political decision
um but what is the your position on
vaccine passports the idea of them
yeah so thank you for um framing
uh the fact that it is a political
decision
it's not um one that a doctor is going
to make or
even advise on um but
i think there's already a lot of talk
um around the whole world about
how vaccines are going to help us get
back to normal
and what that is going to mean for
international travel
what is that going to mean for allowing
tourists to visit
and so forth and i think there is an
international
debate now on an international agenda
and
i wouldn't like to predict where it's
going to land
but really i guess the question is about
if i'm a british citizen um
will there be requirements around
vaccination
placed on me by other countries around
the world
if i wish to go and visit and i think
all i would say is that it's perfectly
plausible that we will
see some countries make those kinds of
decisions
and we will of course if we're
travellers be subject
to those but how it's going to play out
i
i don't know for certain at this point
and obviously the government has
announced that he's going to look at
this pretty carefully
yeah and as you say of course not a
unilateral decision in a global pandemic
what other one else does around the
world matter as well
a question that's coming from andrew
miller about schools with schools
heading back on the 8th of march
why are we not vaccinating teachers as a
priority
right we're vaccinating people as a
priority
who have the highest risk of dying
from covid and after that we'll be
focusing on people who have
a high risk of hospitalization from
covid
and we do now have some data on teachers
from the office for national
statistics i i can't remember the
figures so i'm just going to quickly
peep at them
so um for
teachers of both sexes
the death rate from covid between the
9th of march and the 28th of december
2020 has been 18.4
the baby pardon i've got it by sex 18.4
per 100 thousand for men 9.8
for women teachers and if you compare
that
with the same um age population
and and and sex again uh generally
the figures are 31.4
for males and 16.8
for females so um you know it's clear
that there is no
um excess mortality overall
in teachers compared to people of
equivalent
age and sex in the population if you're
a teacher
um and you have a uh a high risk
condition
or if you're over 50 you're going to be
picked up uh and picked up pretty soon
at the rate where
we're we're moving uh by the um jcvi
priority cohorts
you say you'll be picked up but you can
also see why teachers in those
categories would feel
pretty anxious about going back on the
8th of march um
if we're vaccinating 300 000 400 000
people a day there's what approximately
half a million teachers in
england it would only take a few days
just to get every teach their job
wouldn't it
i can't do the maths um whilst
trying to concentrate on your questions
sophie um yeah of course you know
but but our private stronghold
our priority is to vaccinate people
who are at high risk of dying
okay okay understood um now a question
uh that's come in uh anonymously but
this i think really gets
the heart of what a lot of people will
be feeling
about right now if the vaccine rollout
continues to go well
can life get to normal more quickly than
planned
um the roadmap takes into account
how fast the government thinks this can
be done
safely and takes into account our advice
that each stage needs to be
watched and measured carefully before we
move to the next stage so it's just an
unfortunate fact that if you are
exposed to covid today
you will get symptoms probably in five
days time
from now you will then um
probably take seven to ten days if
you're going to go into hospital
to get to a point where um you know
your breathing is an issue and you need
to go into hospital
and the whole thing just takes time
so if for example you react too quickly
and say oh it's all going
obviously you know look infection rates
coming down um
and you don't wait for that lag
to see what the impact is on
hospitalizations and deaths
then um you're always at risk of getting
it wrong
and going too fast and we've factored
all of that in in these carefully
measured steps and also the steps and
the kind of you know not before dates
um reflect the fact that we're taking
into account
the continued vaccine rollout so
well i think i'd i'd say i underst i
completely get it
you know um you know that we want to go
fast that we want to
um get back to normal as quick as we can
i
completely get it you know i'm desperate
um for the football to be back
but um you know actually i'd rather do
this once
and get it right and not have to make
any kind of um
you know u-turns or back-tracking i'd
rather just go
slowly and steadily and get there in one
go
i can share your pain with wanting
football fans back in stadiums although
part of me thinks that a sheffield
wednesday support myself
i could do without the pain right now of
uh having to go and see too many more
live games
um at the same at the same time though
um you can understand why some people
will be looking at the vaccine data
they'll be listening to you about the
positive results and they'll be thinking
why can't things be sped up
uh mid april when you're gonna have
vaccinated all the nine top priority
groups you hope
which account for 99 of deaths i believe
from kovid so
surely there is room some would say for
things to move a bit quicker
well um right now we've completed
uh priority cohorts one to four with one
dose
we've got to do one to nine with one
dose
and then we have to go back and give
everybody their second dose
and so forth so um you know
yes we've had remarkable results and i'm
really really impressed
with the real world data from scotland
from public health england
and from uh professor hopkins siren
study
in healthcare workers really impressed
with the data
but it's early days and um i think we've
just got to be
really confident um about this before we
go
before we go further just just take it
steady you know we've we've suffered a
long while here
um and i know
people want to kind of get out of it but
at the same time you know it's taken so
long to get this far
it's it's it's taken me uh
over a year of um intense intellectual
effort behind the scenes to
you know get this vaccine program get
the vaccines get the vaccine program
to to where where it is today i don't
want to blow it now
just want to do it at a measured pace
do you think you were talking about
people having to get their second dose
should we expect things to slow down a
little bit as
the second doses start to be rolled out
there is a plan to fit the second doses
in as they are needed
um i i'm not going to tell you about
them but i've seen the trajectories
um for um continuing uh at pace with the
vaccine program
and i think the targets set by the prime
minister are entirely realistic
uh based upon how fast we can go based
upon i
have to say you know i said it on a
previous media
call this morning based on the
incredible efforts
of the clinical um
and volunteer workforce who are putting
together these
these vaccination efforts whether it's
in gp surgeries whether it's in special
vaccination centers
or the mass vaccination centers that the
dedication to just get this battle won
one by one jab jab is is really
heartwarming
um another new view is a question on an
important issue
how and when will we know if we will
need a booster shot
in winter
i guess the science answer to that is
that
um we need further data on how long
immunity or protection will last
after people have had these vaccines
and we will have to take into account
the the emergence of new
variants of the coronavirus over time
which
do have the potential in the long term
to
outwit the current vaccines and require
revaccination so we could end up
revaccinating
either because of waning immunity maybe
not on the whole population maybe in
certain parts of it
and because of the development of new
variants
but you know there's been a lot of talk
uh about
the variant that first emerged or was
first identified
in kent the b117 and whether the
vaccines were currently rolling out
um are effective against the b117
and all of the vaccine data the real
world data i've just
told you about um um really has been
collected uh in a time period
when b117 has been the absolutely
dominant virus in the uk
so yeah these vaccines are absolutely
working against
the so-called kent variant
do we have absolute clarity yet on
vaccines and their effectiveness against
future variants south africa
brazil no we don't at this point i think
we have
moderately high confidence on first
principles
that these vaccines are going to still
reduce serious disease hospitalizations
and deaths
but i think you know it doesn't change
my view over the horizon um
of the fact that there will come a point
where we have to re-vaccinate
possibly with um new strains of
coronavirus vaccine okay yes so much
uncertainty with the new variant uh time
to squeeze in one last question i think
i'm quite interested in this one
actually is someone who's
recently had covered very mildly myself
um have the doctors and scientists
got to the bottom of why kovid is so
serious for some people
that seems to hardly affect others
that's david andrews there in woking
um yes um well the answer to that is a
bit yes but no but
um we we we really have got to the
bottom of why it's
serious in some people in terms of the
major risk factors which are
age age and age
that is absolute driver is the biggest
biggest risk factor
on top of that comes what we call
co-morbidity
people with serious underlying risk
conditions
and we also know that
men are more badly affected consistently
across the ages
and also the obese we know those those
are the big risk factors
so yes at one level we do absolutely
know why
it's more likely to be serious for some
uh than it is for others but i think
what you're getting at really in the
question
is if you take um you know uh
a 50 year old male um
and you um and they both got the same
250 year old males they both got the
same
co-morbidities and they both got the
same body mass index
why does one of them have a mild illness
and one of them end up on the intensive
care unit
within an inch of their lives and that's
really down to
how the body responds to the
um how the immune response
is different in people uh seems to be
very different in people
um uh in relation to the response to
covert infection
and we don't know the answers to all of
that yet there's a
um very detailed um study the isaric
study i-s-a-r-i-c um that is
taking really quite um you know
complicated
biological specimens from volunteers who
are ill with govid
to try and unlock the mysteries the
immunological mysteries of why it
is such and that some people do so badly
and some people
don't seem to be affected hardly at all
and you you i'm glad to say we're
clearly one of one of those but it is a
mystery and so we kind of know it at a
course level
around age and comorbidities we don't
know it at the immunological level yet
that's
uh that's um science work important
science work that needs to be done